so our next guest is a regular here on
the show he is a 20 year professional
institutional future trader he started
his career on the CMA trading floor and
later left open outcry trading pits when
electronic trading started and went on
to trade futures on the screen for
Commerce Bank for three years cargo for
four years and most recently JP Morgan
for eight years here's your chance to
learn from Michael as he discusses the
order flow concepts and tools that he
uses and has taught many other
successful traders Michael brings a
unique perspective in order flow
analysis from someone who's traded at a
for a living at the highest
institutional level for over 20 years
welcome to the show michael altos okay
okay can you hear me okay good I'm doing
all right happy to be here you know it's
tell you man these every day it's like
something new in the markets with with
Trump and these politics it's it's
interesting times to be a trader it
really is it really is I mean do you
believe volatility is still gonna
continue higher you know every time you
think the market can't go any more crazy
next day it's it's it's fascinating you
know it's it's fascinating in the sense
of you know the hope how politics is
intertwined into the markets you know
just this morning right when we're all
asleep in the u.s. you know news started
coming out that oh you know maybe
there's gonna be some agreement in China
and he saw Nasdaq just you know spiked
up about 20 handles which you know it's
just it's just mind-blowing that these
moves that happen nowadays and it didn't
you think you know well that's not
one-off event than a day later the next
day later you get another 30 40 you know
a hundred point move and Nasdaq it's
just it's just great time to be a trader
it really is I remember many times
months and almost years at a time where
it's like watching paint dry
so I'll never complain about volatility
or action I mean that's uh that's that's
a fun way to do it and you know I think
news dissemination I mean we know this
right news dissemination worldwide that
the speed of it compared to what it was
when you and I started trading it's just
I mean you
can't even compare it right right I mean
it's it's you know she's talking earlier
come on my wife about this you know I
remember back when Greenspan gave his
irrational exuberance speech and you
know that happened like at nine o'clock
Central Time 9:00 or 9:30 and you know
the markets just went berserk and I
remember I was working on the trading
desk overnight I would trade you know
the Asian session into Europe into the
US and nobody knew what was going on you
don't know what there was no Twitter
there's no Facebook you know there was
cable news you know but you know hardly
anybody really watched it you know they
would just do stories on you know
dancing cats and stuff like that but you
know it's now it's like you know just
like the other day you know I remember I
think it's just yesterday you know stuff
happens so fast it's hard to keep track
of the days you know one of the guys
from the Fed is talking and boom you
know market
spiked like that it's you know worse in
the old days people be scrambling around
you know what's the news you know what's
happened you know we think you know 10
minutes you know have 15 minutes
sometimes I figure out what happened now
you know news just gets out there so
fast that you know it's it's one of
those things where you know you can't
trade around it you got to react to it
and most importantly you know you have
to have some risk management in place
for it because that's you know these
moves are going to get you know it's
gonna run you over if you don't have any
sort of protection no sugar or anything
like that for sure let me ask you a
question about that so I know you trade
on order flow and you're really just
watching the paper and watching where
the money is coming in and out do you
ever find that news and knowing what's
happening can get in the way and
sometimes it's better to just purely
trade on the order flow and just to read
what the what the what the money is
doing yeah you know it's it's one of
those things you know because people
always say you know do you have a bias
coming into the market in the morning
and you know you do your preparation and
you know you could spend you know an
hour
preparing then you know by 9:00 a.m. you
know a number comes out or something or
somebody says something and you know
your preparation is just thrown out the
window and so you know you're sort of
back as
one you're better in my opinion at least
you know having a trade plan sticking
with it you know if the market does this
okay that's what I'm going to do you
know if it doesn't do it what it's
supposed to do then okay I'm gonna you
know do something else or you know step
away from the screen or reassess its you
know I don't like to get married into a
way of thoughts especially you know
nowadays with things just happening so
fast
that you know you could you know no
sense dying on your own swords they
always you know I this markets got to go
up you know because because of
everything I've done in my analysis no
it doesn't have to go up because it
could just take one event and sometimes
it's just that one thing that can change
the entire outlook of you know the
market in the near term you know the
long term yeah you may be correct you
know just like you know a good way to
think of it is you know back in the
2000s right and you had the whole
commodity run-up and but at that time
you also had a lot of hedge funds
getting into commodities all of a sudden
so there's a lot of hot money in the
market so you know I knew a lot of guys
that were commodity traders you know
starting hedge funds they would be right
on the market prediction you know over
the six-month term but the intraday
swings cuz all all the hot money going
in and out of the market you know their
risk parameters you know they'd be
stopped out of positions so they would
win the battle but lose the war so you
know it's it's well as things don't get
stuck on thinking you know it's supposed
to do this because you know this number
came out yesterday and it is very
bullish but you know so even though the
market is going down don't think I gotta
buy more it was there's a reason why
it's going down you may not know what it
is right now but you know everybody else
has got a better you know for whatever
way that they trade is you know weighing
on the market so you know don't you know
my only advice is you know don't get so
caught up in you know trying to be a
hero and predicting you know where the
market is going to be you know down the
line or you know say you know yeah I
predicted that this market would go up
by the end of the week you know but in
the meantime you're suffering a big
drawdown it's not
and what about getting caught up trying
to figure out why the markets moving
versus just watching the the paper where
do you stand on that well you know
because you see love yeah instead of you
know they get paralyzed trying to figure
well wait a minute I need to know I need
to know what's happening in the world
that's causing this and then they spend
five ten minutes as opposed to
methodology watching the order flow if
you know it's it's one of these things
you know back when I was a young buck in
this industry I used to tell somebody a
good friend of mine who sort of helped
me get in the industry said yeah you
know I want to learn Japanese so that I
can you know read the Japanese news this
is back in the 90s you know so I could
have a so I could trade Japanese yen
then I realized that you know once I saw
you know a lot of those news that comes
out is already baked into how the
markets reacting and if it's not
immediately baked in it's going to get
there relatively soon I think the way
you know because what moves the markets
it's people right it's people reacting
you know or people have their own point
of view and that's really what's moved
in the market you so you got to react to
that not off of oh you know there's
Trump says no more negotiations was with
China well that move the market yeah of
course that's going to move the market
that's an obvious obvious thing but you
know trying to profit off that in the
near term is is you know it's hard you
just got to watch where the flow is
going in it's like you know if you run a
business you know just a shop selling
you know fruit or something you're gonna
make your decisions based on you know
what people are buying from you you know
if they're buying more apples now you
probably gotta buy more apples to sell
to them you know if they're not buying
pears
you're probably not gonna spend invest
so much you know in pairs and you make
your decisions based off of what people
are are doing in the market makes
perfect sense last thing I want to point
out here before you get going is I just
want to do a quick brief just in case
people don't know your history will you
give a 30 to 60 second history what you
owe your gonna do anything I just want
to make sure because because that's a
unique part of what you bring
that most people don't have this cargill
and commerce from JPMorgan it's
extremely rare to find somebody that's
out ating traders that's actually been
on that side of the desk right I mean
I've never even been on that senators
Canella I've always been a local but to
find somebody who's really spent that
much time trading money for the huge
banks and using all their tools is a
really big value that it's very hard to
find so just want to make sure that's
covered in your intro and I will go
ahead and turn it over to you now
let me make you the making organizer
here so you can answer any questions
that come in anyone who has questions as
you guys know a few of you did a good
job during NIC Santiago's presentation
and asked a few questions we always love
when people ask questions everybody does
that the presenters do and we do so the
more you can do on that the better and I
will turn over to you and Michael you've
got about 30 minutes and we'll take you
back up here about 1055 Pacific okay
okay great I try to make sure you can
see my screen okay
I think advances in order flow that's
right all right thanks Jack all right
guys so what I'm gonna talk about today
is the new advances in order flow and
you know what that means you know order
flow is not something that's just been
around for you know the last 20 years
there's you know it's been around for
well over a hundred years it just hasn't
been at this level and my goal for you
today is to Folds want to explain how
price tells us what's happening and how
volume tells you how it's happening with
either the commitment or lack of
commitment in the market and also I'm
gonna give you two order flow setups
they start using in your trading
tomorrow you know it's one thing to
learn about order flow but you want to
know how you can use it in your trading
and you know my goal for you today is is
to give you two setups that you can look
for if you know you want to add order
flow to your trading you know they're
not overly complicated they're very
simple you can start using in your
trading and again you know if you stick
around till the end I'll show you how to
get a copy of my book trading and order
flow he's not going to be the actual
hard copy book it's going to be a
digital download it's 150 pages but it's
a good read you know if you're new to
order flow so as Jack was explaining you
know a bit about my background you know
most recently since my last four or five
years
I've been running order flows calm but
prior to that I spent eight years as
vice president of futures trading at
JPMorgan I spent three years as the
license your ex trader at Commerce Bank
in Chicago I spent four years at Cargill
it's a big commodity trading company oh
they account for about thirty percent of
all US grain exports about 25 percent of
all meat exports but they're in every
type of commodity that you could imagine
I was a trading desk manager there I
spent two years at ETF man as a global
macro trader on their desk trading
everything you know all these strange
commodities that's what we traded there
I started on the CMA floor with Dean
Witter but I left the floor after about
two years and I went to their upstairs
trading desk when electronic trading
started taking off you know being in my
early 20s and you know having a little
bit of computer background I realized
you know electronic trading is what I
want to be into and you know I did that
starting in the mid 90s and my career
took off from there now again you know
it's important to you know the reason I
put that up there this you know brief
timeline of my history is because you
know what I talked about with the order
flow you know came through working at
different trading jobs you know working
with different traders you know we would
always be on the trading desk you know
shooting around ideas we all have big
orders we got to execute and we want to
do it with minimal market impact you
know nowadays you have execution now
goes where you could sort of hide what
you're doing but you know what all that
activity shows up in the order flow but
the thing is you have to know how to
look for it now I left JPMorgan right
after my daughter was born my first
daughter and I was trading order flow
for my own account I started writing my
book trading order flow which you get at
the end and I was using an order flow
software from another company but all
that the software choices that were
available were just basic footprint
order flow charts you know and I was
doing a lot of calculations by hand and
you know in my head
but you know I know computers can do
that analysis for you so you know I met
with a programmer that was really
familiar with order flow and a footprint
chart and I said hey you know can you
take this form of analysis and put it
into the software let the software do it
for you and you know I started talking
to some other traders showing them my
charts and they're like hey man you know
can I get a copy of that software and
that's how order flows was born so you
know what I'm presenting here is what
I've developed for myself that built my
trading career on hopefully you can find
things you could use in your own trading
or adapt for your own trading again you
know anything anybody says whether it's
me or you know whether it's Paul Tudor
Jones you evaluate it and decide if it's
something you can use in your own
trading now again you know don't take my
word for it you know a lot of people
have been using my software for years
you know and they tell them it's very
helpful in allowing them to see things
in the market that they couldn't see
before you know and and that's really
what you want right you want to be able
to see things and understand what's
happening in the market now again you
know before I begin disclaimer
you know trading is not for everybody
you know it takes a certain mentality it
takes a certain dedication you know it's
not something you could just sit down
and start playing you know you can't sit
down at a piano and just start you know
playing a concerto right you have to
understand what the different keys are
what the pedals do and how to put the
different notes together and it's the
same way in order flow now you know most
people think trading with order flow is
this you know just looking at a ticker
tape just seeing the prices go by but
it's it's not you know this is what it
looks like it's like a waterfall of data
and you know if you're not no human
brain can process this information you
know we all joke about you know I was
born in the matrix I could figure out no
you can't and why put yourself through
that you know you're just going to do
yourself a disservice and you're going
to end up losing money now the problem
with trying to read raw data sometimes
it's too messy and it's overwhelming
what you need to do is you need to put
it into an easy to read format and
that's what a volume footprint chart
does for you you know so you could see
how trades are being executed in the
market is it being traded on the bid is
it being traded on the offer is there
more aggressive trading is there less
aggressive trading you know our is
volume picking up you know there's so
many little things about the information
that you can
use and make good trading decisions so
once you have the data and easy to read
format you could begin to understand
what's happening in the market you know
so think about it right when you go
outside right you can look at the
thermometer you're gonna see what the
temperature is you know it's the same
way if you're gonna take a trade you
want to know what's going on in the
market you know our buyers being
aggressive our sellers being aggressive
are is there a lack of buying interest
you know so many questions you could
have depending on where market is and
that's what order flow allows you to see
now you know very basic stuff you got to
realize what do we know about how
markets trade well trade is conducted
through a two-way auction right there's
a bid price there's an offer price so
you know this example you know say the
market is twenty nine fifty five and a
quarter bid offered at twenty nine fifty
five and a half that's the two-way
auction people are happy to buy it at
fifty five and a quarter people are
happy to sell it at fifty five and a
half however no trade is going to occur
until someone becomes aggressive until
the buyer goes and lifts the offer at
fifty five and a half he is being
aggressive or a seller that wants to
sell something is going to sell at fifty
five and a quarter so once you
understand that the market trades into a
auction you can understand the different
types of traders right there's passive
traders there the traders that buy on
the bid or sell on the offer
you know they wait for the market to
come for them right there they're not in
a rush to get into the trade you know
they're happy to buy it at 2950 five and
a quarter you know they think oh that's
what is it that's what it's worth that's
what it's worth to me so that's what I'm
gonna pay at fifty five and a half not
that's too expensive
now another trader could come in and say
no you know I think this price is going
up
I think fifty five and a half is a good
price and they will buy it they're the
what is called the aggressive trader
they don't wait for the market to come
for them they trade at the market they
buy the offer or they sell into the bid
you know if someone if you think that
the price is going down you're not going
to just sit on the offer you want to get
in right you want to participate in the
market movement so you're going to sell
at the bid at twenty nine fifty five and
a quarter
so once you understand the difference
between traders and how they trade
against each other past the buyers
versus aggressive sellers passive
sellers versus aggressive buyers then
you can start interpreting the order
flow footprint chart now you know
there's there's a lot of information on
a footprint chart and a lot of people
get scared you know they see numbers
there immediately scared of the large
numbers they immediately think oh my
gosh you know I got no math no you don't
need to know you know calculus or
anything like that
now there's three building blocks of
order flow and on the footprint chart
that you that every trader needs to know
in my opinion it's the Delta C
imbalances and it's the point of control
and we'll go through each of those
really quick so the Delta is the net
difference in a bar between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers and it'll
appear on the bottom and you can see it
down in here Delta 497 Delta 345 each
bar has a delta 157 minus 71 positive 41
if it's positive then you're gonna say
buyers are in control if it's negative
sellers are in control now in general
there's going to be instances where you
have you know a down candle a red candle
with positive Delta and that means
something I'm not gonna get into that
today but you know there's little
nuances in the order flow that you can
profit from now the next thing is
imbalances and again you know remember
markets trade in a two-way auction and
what you're doing with imbalances is
you're measuring the volume traded on
the bid versus the offer and if it's
greater than four to one in general you
could adjust your imbalance threshold
you know some people use 10 to one some
people use three to one then you'd
consider it an imbalance and as you can
see like on this green bar right here
you got zero against 115 that's an
imbalance 0 against 157 that's an
imbalance these are buying imbalances up
here at the top of the bar you have 257
against 3 so when it was 170 for 58 bid
offered at 59 it's real are traded on
the offer to 57 traded on the bid
so there was some selling into this bid
as this bar was closing you know this is
a one-minute bar chart and it's just
telling you you know there's things that
you could read into that you know you
can see where price is being absorbed by
bigger traders now point control point
of controls are simple and every bar has
a point of control and it's the price
level in the bar where the most volume
traded you know and there'll be a box a
rectangle around it now some of these
bars again this is my own software okay
so I don't use any other software but
you know my software what it will do is
if there's a point of control that's
either supportive in the market or
offering resistance for resistance it
will color it purple if it was
supportive point of control it would
color it blue so you'd have support and
resistance acting in the order file you
can see it at an instant so now the next
thing is you know one of the reasons
most traders fail is because they focus
too much only on price right once you
understand the relationship between the
buyers and sellers at prices then you
are start to understand the market you
know and what I say you know most
traders become focused on price now they
don't take into account volume you know
the volume that's traded on the bid or
the volume that was traded on the offer
at that price you know not all prices
are created equal you know you could
have one price that trades you know
fifteen contracts where the next price
trades you know a thousand contracts
well that thousand contracts is probably
very important information you know
don't you want to know if there's you
know a thousand contracts traded at a
particular price and the market came off
you know that's you know what Jack and I
were just discussing earlier is you know
the the paper that's coming into the
market and paper that's been resting
order sitting in the market you know
those are important areas that traders
trade around and I'm going to show you
an example in shortly so when you look
at an order flow chart you know honestly
you know for most people first time they
look at a footprint chart they look at
this and then just scratch their head
shake their heads you know this is
stupid and I got time to learn this well
you're not analyzing every single price
you got to take into account what you
know about order flow
and put it in a bigger picture context
now if you look at a bar chart right
this is when it's this mini Dow a
one-minute chart okay ask you you know
by looking at this chart is there any
reason to be buying off this low you
know off this low we had this nice you
know basically a hundred point rally up
off this low you know as as a trader
sometimes you got to be playing
detective and sort of putting the clues
together as to what's happening in the
market now if you're looking at this
chart honestly I can't see any major
reason to be buying off this low at all
you know if you're using a moving
average or something you know by the
time it's telling you you know but time
it crosses above the average you're
ready fifty points into the move you
know and so you've missed it so look at
the order flow this is the exact same
time period this is that low right here
what do we see you know the you gotta
play a game over what do we know well I
know I've got my low but I know I got
positive Delta coming in at the low okay
what does that mean it means that we hit
a new low but instead of more selling
instead you have aggressive buying
coming into the market you got a
positive Delta one twenty five also in
the bar you're seeing one two three four
five six seven
buying imbalances in the bar so you know
that the aggressive traders are active
in there so you know once you start
putting those pieces together you start
forming a view of the market alright so
your view at this point is I don't think
this market is going to go down instead
I think the market is going to go up you
know anytime you hit a high or low you
got to be asking is this market going to
keep going down or is this market
potentially going to turn around and go
higher and that's where order flow comes
in by looking at the volume that's being
traded am i looking at what's going
through you can get a good idea you get
a grasp of what the market participation
is you know what the commitment of
traders is in the sense that you know
our traders getting along and you see
here you know net traders net long 125
on this bar on the low that's important
information
it's not- you know if it was negative
I'd be worried that this market still
got some selling into it you know people
are still interested in selling the
market so you know what makes order flow
so powerful is it allows the trader to
see early signs of a move about to
happen you know we've all looked at
charts it's at all that was a great move
you know you could have taken that long
because of this or taking that short
because of that but you know as a trader
you're in the moment right you got to
make that decision and oftentimes you
got to make it very fast you know within
seconds but you have to know what to
look for now this was just yesterday
this is a mini Dow this is a 1-minute
chart you know when I before I got into
working in the training industry I used
to keep charts by hand at home now there
was no overnight session in the sense of
no Globex and so the seamy would open
you know at 7:20 on the currency's and
closed at 2:00 o'clock and that was for
all intents and purposes the trading
session for that day in a currency you
know we didn't people didn't follow the
forex markets or anything like that you
know the only people that traded forex
back then were the interbank dealers and
I used to sit there I used to look at
these yeast and get allotted bars like
this open year it's low I have a big
range close on its high and I used to
think gosh is there a way to to see what
you know what is about to happen before
you get that big move
you know I'd be looking on the charts
and you know people say well you know
you got one two three double triple
bottom yeah okay you know then people
say I'll draw a trendline here okay no I
wanted something more definitive okay
because you know you you could draw a
trendline here
and the market could just hug the
trendline and keep going down then
people say we got to trade the breakout
well by that time you gave up you know a
third of the move already you know if
you're following some moving average
again you're giving up a third of the
move already you know I want to be clued
in as soon as possible because that's
where you're gonna make more money
basically you know if you're getting
into trades late then it's going to
reduce the amount of money that you're
going to make plain and simple right you
know this is a 50 point move but if you
get into
after the markets already moved 20
points well he just gave up you know 40
percent of your profits so you know I
wanted a way that would allow me to
understand what's happening in the
run-up right before that big move up and
you know that's what order flow allows
you to do it allows you to see what's
happening in the market now this is the
order flow chart right this is the big
bar up you know nice heavy volume but
again a one-minute chart so you got a
full minute to analyze this you know
this is not like looking at it on
nanoseconds or even milliseconds
yes I'm just looking at a one minute
chart and what do I see I see right
before the big run-up I see this bar
look I got one two three four five
buying imbalances in there so I know
traders are being aggressive I could see
the volumes that they're trading you
know 110 84 you know they're just
lifting all the offers with impunity you
know do you see any type of volume like
that immediately preceding the ac-119
you know 119 in 84 in the earlier bars
what's the big volume 30 contracts you
know here's one with 54 and here's a 40
in 49 but in general you know 20 to 30
contracts someone just came in and
lifted you know over 200 contracts right
here they're being very aggressive
I see the strong Delta 194 do you see
any strong Delta like that well here's
119 okay that's strong 194 is almost
double that so I'm seeing signs that hey
you know what this market is potentially
about to take off you know do I want to
be long or do I want to be short you
know we had been trending lower you know
going down going down going down but
then BOOM buyer stepped in you know
that's what you want to look for in the
order flow so order flow shows you
what's happening right now in the market
so you can react right now now this is
yesterday this is the Nasdaq this time
oh it's a thirty-second chart
okay people ask you know what time frame
is best for order flow well
yeah if you trade order flow you're more
of a short-term trader you know I think
anything less than five minutes benefits
you if you're analyzing the order flow
but that's not to say you can't look at
water flow over on a 30-minute chart you
know there's different ways to use the
order flow a very good friend of mine
trades order flow and he trades he looks
at footprints for 30 minutes and but
he's looking for very specific things
there's so many different ways to use
order flow you know the way that I use
it is my way you know but that's not to
say that's the only way so here's a 30
second chart mark is trending down okay
going lower lower lower you know I got
imbalances coming in here negative Delta
okay then you sure form in this bottom
starts coming up okay so if I'm short
you know I see the market going sideways
you know and do I see anything big in
the order flow Tommy you know I'll stay
short you know that I still see negative
signs and the order flow not really if
I'm looking at the Delta I'm seeing now
positive Delta's down here I'm seeing
green you know so that's a sign that you
know if I was short potentially the move
is over so I get to this bar here on the
end with the blue arrow I put the blue
arrow so it's easy to see again what do
I see I see a very strong positive Delta
134 again do you see any big positive
Delta's in here the biggest ones 27 nope
14 nothing you know no big positive
tells us but I know buyers are coming in
volumes picked up 388 in here as you
look at the volumes in here you know 192
you know 182 248 263 you know you know I
know people are coming into the market
why are they coming in as buyers or
coming in as sellers - coming in as
buyers
what else do I see I see one two three
four five six seven buying imbalances in
there okay
so if I was short and I see this bar
throw out my whole short bias I see this
bar I got to get long off this bar right
now this is a thirty-second chart so you
got full 30 seconds to analyze what's
going on again you know I'm not saying
that you got a
all of a sudden it's gonna take you five
minutes it's not it should take you very
quick you should be able to recognize
what's happening and act on it next bar
stronger positive Delta 229 again
another big up bar this time you got
three buying imbalances in there okay
bars move from you know basically 67-68
all the way up to 70s you know 74 73 74
okay so you know even if you've missed
this move right here right and said ah
you know I didn't get long off this bar
next bar is up you're sort of kicking
yourself thinking oh my gosh I'm an
idiot you know I missed it well you know
usually when there's buying big buying
or big selling coming into the market it
takes a while for it to exhaust all
right look at this third bar here it
goes from about 71 all the way up to you
know 83 another big strong positive
Delta you know you're looking at 463 you
know so what's happening in the Delta
volume is increased in 388 883 1847
deltas increasing 134 229 463 and you
still keep going higher alright the next
bar after that 82 all the way up to 94
okay
but really you know you shouldn't be
getting in here up here in the 80s
realistically you should be getting in
somewhere in this bar between 68 to 74
you know even in the next bar you still
had some time to get in between you know
71 and 74 as well next thing you know
within a minute you're trading in the
90s you know then the next bar finally
gets all the way up to 99 to
three-quarters and it starts dropping
back okay you know the move is finally
over you know we still got positive
Delta though but you know markets turned
down now you got you know it's probed
higher hit there and just you know
started selling off you know this is not
the time to get into the move the time
to get into the move is right after you
start seeing the pickup in Delta seeing
the aggressive buying coming in in the
buying imbalances in there
you know then finally the next bar
starts coming down but you know you had
this whole bar you had 30 seconds to
pull the trigger on that trade you know
this is not a range based chart or a
wrinkle based chart where you know you
get 8 bars in 10 seconds if the market
is really moving this is a 30 seconds
you have time to react so again you know
that's just one example now as a blank
slide here so now that you have an
understanding of what order flow is and
the key components you can start
understanding what's actually happening
in the market and when we get into now
are some of the setups so the first one
is trap traders and this type of trap
traders there's different types of trap
trading in the market and you know I
don't like the term trap traders because
it sort of connotates you know some
nefarious trading that's going on but
you know there's times that swing highs
or swing lows where short term traders
run into longer term traders with the
opposite view
and those long term traders are the ones
that are going to absorb the short term
traders and then turn the market on them
and move it in the opposite direction so
what you're going to look for let's
point a control on the extreme of the
bar which signifies a longer timeframe
trader absorbing the short time frame
trader you know not everybody trades on
the same timeframe and that's a hard
concept for a lot of new traders to
understand you know everyone thinks that
while all the bank's trade on 4-hour
chart no they don't you know or all the
banks are now a 5 minute chart
no they don't everyone has their own
different chart duration that they're
looking at and make up so what you're
looking for in the order floor I talked
about point of control what I'm looking
for is extreme point of control on a red
bar on the top right my software will
draw will color it in as magenta
Purple's was easy to see if it was blue
it would indicate support of mine and
what else do you see you see the
aggressive selling coming in here I mean
you just compare what's traded on the
bid and the offer you know on the way
down so let's tell me
sellers are in control here right so I
know that coming up in here there's
resistance selling there's somebody up
here with offers right there supply up
there now you know on a by right my
software will draw a
you know a blue point of control it
tells you their support so what's
happened is you rallied up market starts
coming off but they're supportive buying
here in the market it's stopping this
move lower so all these people think of
this markets going down or selling into
this bid but there's some guy there
saying yeah I buy it I buy it and you
know absorbing all that selling that's
going on and sure enough what happens
market starts ticking back up next bars
boom on the way up this is gold that I'm
looking at here you know it works on you
know different markets here's another
gold chart your high of the day a point
of control on the extreme looking at the
volume on the way down you know seventy
two against fifty five sixty eight
against 46:17 is thirty four eight
against one right I know that the
sellers are in control just looking at
the volume horizontally they're in
control as well you know is what is this
one crude oil one minute chart mark is
coming down it starts popping up get a
little bit of the bid but there's
sellers in their offering supply market
comes off boom trades lower again emini
z-- for range chart markets coming off
just like the crude gets catches a bid
starts ticking back up someone's got
supply they're offering it right out
here at the high of this bar whoa look
at this what's the volume trader
underneath that one 132 26 that's
nothing compared to 47 50 666 Eamonn
he's also high the day this time
fourteen hundred and twenty there's 1420
traded here market couldn't get past it
there's somebody absorbing all that mind
you know I hear that buyer thinking this
is it we're hitting high again
we're gonna break out but there's
someone absorbing it you're stuck you're
gonna get trapped in the market and what
happens on the way down look at the
volume is 544 four one four one one six
187 against what three three six three
29:56 82 there's no math involved
nothing like that it's just you know
common sense now this is an interesting
one this was Nasdaq yesterday there was
this big bid in here 182 contracts right
the market starts rallying up comes off
there's a big buyer in here this is
about what understanding where the paper
is in the market if you see that
something like that that's telling you
if somebody stepped in and is
supporting this market this is very good
information you know to use as a trader
and what happens boom over the next five
minutes you know it was a 30 second
chart you know over the next two minutes
market rallies you know about 15 20
handles so the next one to talk about is
the overwhelming imbalances in a bar and
I sort of talked about it earlier on
that previous example is when there's
more than five imbalances right so this
is my software we'll put a box around it
they don't pull it purple so you can
just see really quick this one is very
simple it's a visual setup you got a box
around it you were sort of breaking out
of an area boom okay I get long in the
next bar look at that you know from 53
all the way up to 58 new highs of the
day you know it doesn't take there's you
know doesn't take rocket science there's
some science involved but it's not
rocket science again here's another one
you know from Oh 8 o 9 all the way up to
15 in the next bar you know you're
looking for the signs in what's
happening in the market before the move
happens right you're not analyzing it
down here after the move happened no you
can see here I see well my gosh gold you
know I got big seller coming into the
market you know I got five imbalances in
this bar that has ten price levels
that's probably important right and you
see how the markets sold off nicely now
again you know I'd be doing you a
disservice if I said you know every
single time it happens you know it's a
big winning trade now sometimes what
happens is the market goes sideways you
know you could do some analysis
obviously say well gosh you know if I
got such a big bar that's probably the
move you know ideally you'd like to see
it happen on a smaller bar not a bar
that in the gold covers you know three
bucks but you know you got a you know
sometimes you got to use your your head
you know even if you got short in here
okay he's just going sideways cover it
don't wait for it to come all the way
back up the O's you know three dollars
against you to get out as euro currency
right and you start putting this stuff
together you know this is a setup and
here they talk about a lot with my users
the ratio and divergence but here's
multiple imbalances go sideways before
falls over not today just in the morning
really quick
I want to talk about this this was
Nasdaq one-second chart again I don't
advocate people's trade on a one-second
chart but if you you know you got to
really be a gunslinger what happened
right leading up into this move all
right that's the move
what do you see tons of buying
imbalances here buying imbalances here
yeah you got some selling imbalances
here okay one order but more buying
imbalances coming in what are you going
to do put a gun to your head you know
get longer get short you're going to get
long and look what happened boom next
second one second market went from 94
all the way up to 17 next couple of bars
up up up this is a trade setup I talk a
lot about for my users a ratio and
divergence but again multiple selling
imbalances now and the market comes
right back down you know is it a 30
point move up and a 30 point move down
in all about you know 10 seconds so
hopefully by now you can see how just
two pieces of order flow point control
and imbalances give you amazing trading
opportunities you just need to know what
to look for again if you're interested
in my software you go to order flows
comm slash off to oft to HTML or just go
to order flows and it'll take you there
now if you want my book you just go to
order flows com slash book HTML and
you'll take you to this page you got
enter your name and email address and
click Submit and you'll get access to
the digital download for it so thanks
Jack I'll throw it back to you see if
there's any questions from users or
attendees hey Michael great presentation
as always I'm just want to point out
here that it type in the box anyone that
I wants to get this free digital copy of
Michaels order flow books just you can
click the link right here I typed it in
is order flows calm for slash book you
can just type it in there and you'll get
the book I know we've had great reviews
on this book you know this this book
tell us about how you wrote it and what
the purpose of was it because we've had
so many people respond back to us saying
that it's been so helpful and they
finally got an understanding of how the
the paper and order flow works in the
markets oh sure sure you know I've been
wanting to write a book for a long time
you know I used to keep a lot of going
back to the 90s I used to keep notes on
everything that was happening in the
market but more fundamental stuff
you know I was never really a
fundamentalist but you know a lot of
people that trade in the banks and
commodity firms are big fundamentalist
and then as I started moving more away
from fundamentals and getting more into
technicals by around 2010 or so I
started making notes on what I was
seeing in the markets you know in the
depth of markets I used to be a big dome
trader you know because when you're
trading through the exchange you know
basically the front-end systems
early on that's what you had you had a
dome there was no you know footprints or
anything like that back in the 90s and
you know you just see things in the
markets and you'd have to you know sort
of make a mental catalog of things and
then when I left JPMorgan you know they
had this thing I couldn't do anything in
the business for like a year
you know otherwise they'd come and see
you but so I just started writing this
thing I took a bit longer than I had
imagined and you know I just started
putting down all my thoughts and and
talking with other traders about what we
would see in the order flow and you know
so this book is really sort of the
culmination of you know 20 years worth
of institutional trading and you know
try to understand it from a traders
point of view rather than someone just
sort of come in here and looking at a
market and trying to put the pieces
together you know I like to sort of give
traders a bit of a background on you
know on why things happen in the market
and you know executing a 3,000 loud
order versus executing a three loud
order there's a big difference and it's
going to impact the market and you know
you have to sort of understand that
mentality but the thing with order flow
is once it's executed in the market it's
there for everybody to see so you know
as a trader you need to know how to see
it and you know that's that's one of the
reasons why I wanted to have a book cuz
there's really no no book on there you
know on the subject it's just a lot of
you know random postings online and
people were very you know people that
were real you know the original order
flow traders you know back in the day
where the floor traders you know the
market makers and stuff and you know
that's just information that you know I
hate to say people take with the grave
to them but it was never really
you know shared and and you know among
other among other people and you know I
would receive stuff online I just like
you know shake my head I said you know
there's got to be a better resource for
for traders to go to so that's how I
decided to write the book yeah I'm so
glad you did I mean I learned it all
obviously from the floor and and I mean
none of us put it down in writing I mean
it just got passed down or you know
trained to the guy next year and never
was put into writing mainly because I
don't think it's like look trading with
a moving average that's been written
about you know thousands of times right
but I just don't think um
you know the the people from the floor
aren't really the type of people in the
old days that would be sitting down and
writing a book let's be honest so that
type of crowd I love the guys yeah I
mean honestly it's it's it's one of
those things where you know it's
information it's you know I look back
now you know it's like my I was living
overseas for you know 15 years and you
know I very rarely see my parents and
then I started when I moved back to the
US my parents my dad would be telling me
all these stories when he was a kid
and then he's like you know I'm just
telling you these stories because if I
don't tell you they'll be lost forever
you know he goes away and it's a bit
like that with with trading you know I
mean there's so much knowledge from you
know there's so many good traders you
know on the floor that you know it's
just it's I hate to say it's a waste but
there's so much information that you
know that they have on trading that you
know they just never it's just never
gonna come out for people that's why I
like doing you know these presentations
like this is just sort of you want to
share the knowledge you know and
hopefully you know somebody somewhere
can you know get that information and
become successful in their career or in
their trading with it and with that
everyone should download the book
because once Michael goes away he's gone
and then that's not for a long time but
anyway all jokes aside if the book is
super useful I mean really useful
there's there's a million books on
trading out there nowadays and this is
one that it can be applied to any market
I mean any market where you can actually
see depth a level two or
order flow or any of that this can be
applied to which is pretty much all of
them nowadays so there's no doubt that
this this is helpful
I mean of the hundreds of people in the
room every single person should be
downloading this book there's zero
reason not to it's order flows dot-com
for charts book and I've ticked it in
here the window actually you have HTML
let me just click oh that doesn't work
actually oh let me three type it in here
okay oh can we make sure that works that
just took us to there we go that goes to
the right one yeah yes lots of people
saying that they kind of get it from
that link apologies it is dot HTML at
the end and so I mean some of the some
of the questions people that are that
are asking I'm here I'm just gonna kind
of sum up a few of them so you can kind
of go through but some general stuff
does this work with any type of trading
platforms does it work with stocks and
options I mean I know the answer is but
go ahead yeah you know it's the there's
so many different platforms nowadays you
know obviously my software was it works
with NinjaTrader
I have a partnership with a guy that has
four sierracharts tradestation I don't
know if they have it but you know
there's a lot of software now has
versions of a footprint so whether you
have my software or not you know you can
take what I've applied as long as you
have a footprint chart on your software
you know just a native volume footprint
chart you could apply what I was talking
about you just got it to look for it now
does it work on stocks in Forex welcome
with Forex is the data is not
centralized so you know you have a lot
of different sources of data and you
know people don't realize that all these
brokers that they trade what these small
brokers are actually front-ends coming
from banks like Goldman Sachs or
Barclays and you know so there's
different bid ass and slightly different
data that's coming out so you know I
know people that use order flow use my
own footprint charts they watch the GME
data and then they trade in the forex
market for stocks oh cool
it really depends you should have you
know I look at stocks but I look at the
main
big stocks that trade a lot of volume
right cuz you're trying to analyze
volume so you should have something to
analyze basically you know so I tend to
stick to the bigger stocks like Apple
and etc right right
understood totally understood well cool
thanks for being on the show Michael
always awesome super insightful
everybody should download the book click
the second link I types in it the actual
correct one and it's always great having
here any last comments before we go no
again you know thanks for having me here
and again you know people you know
trading is a journey right you got to
start somewhere but important thing is
you got to start and you know if you ask
a lot of traders where they are now
versus where they are one year ago you
leave they find that they take a lot of
twists and turns you know stay the past
stay the course and you know you can get
to the finish line
as long as you were willing to put in
the time and effort basically great good
information
thanks Michael have a great rest of the
day and the rest of the trading week and
we will see you again here soon all
right bye-bye